and so tonight
we're going to celebrate like we got a
second chance in life up in here and
we're going to celebrate a chance to be
able to do it better and do it bigger
and celebrate each other from incredible
performances to exciting awards and a
first-time host diddy's hosting first of
all so you already know if you don't
know like a ditty party
man it's about to go crazy up in here
the whole family showed up to support
diddy i'm so so so so i could say 10
more so's but so excited he's been
practicing for this for so long and we
can't wait to see it on the stage
tonight the show is going to be wicked
award shows in vegas mean our local
headliners show up i've always loved las
vegas beautiful people great place to
raise your kids and a lot of fun to have
a little residency well we're so happy
to have you here you can just give a
little wave and i love you guys so much
i can't wait to come back and see again
if you're a las vegas local you're one
of us yeah yeah definitely i mean i
usually don't go out until the sun go
down but today i make an exception for
paul some of the big winners of the
night include olivia rodrigo for best
female artist drake for top billboard
artist and we caught up with the
billboard music award winner for best
dance electronic album you're nominated
for best dance electronic album how does
that feel i mean you just keep talking
the charts and you're always doing
something it's been it's been fun so
i'm just glad it you know relates with
my fans and you know that's who i love
the most so i'm just happy to be here
the nominees and the performers were
bringing big energy to the mgm stage hey
you are performing tonight here with
billboards what can we expect to see
a lot of big energy i told him i'm
performing like this new version of big
energy so it feels fresh and fun
and y'all better be look y'all in for a
treat i hope you all ready
when the carpet rolls up tonight these
performers shift focus to their next
project
i have a project coming out next month
me and harry fraud it's called mondega
june 24th what's next for you what can
you my music a project i'm about to
leave for atlanta to start filming this
movie so all is well god is good
congratulations enjoy tonight thank you
everyone on the silver carpet was
definitely showing some vegas love yeah
shout out las vegas what happens in
vegas stays in vegas
[Music]